[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio modo
bienvenidos a escala en parís en emisión
de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español hoy vamos a viajar a una de
las zonas más apartadas de colombia la
guajira una zona inhóspita y al mismo
tiempo plena de belleza donde se ubica
la etnia wayúu para hablar de este tema
saludamos aquí en nuestro estudio a anna
smith doctor en antropología social y
tecnología y autora del libro publicado
por la edición del arma ton sexo y
territorio en colombia mujeres
autóctonas en lucha siglo 21 aún no
publicado en español anna bienvenida a
esta escala en parís gracias en la
guajira es una zona inhóspita al mismo
tiempo rica ha sido perturbada
perturbado con el paso de los años por
una serie de factores externos su
investigación se adentra en la
estructura social precisamente de la
etnia wayúu en la estructura en la
dominación que existe entre hombres y
mujeres la relación de dominación que
existe en este terreno que le llevó a
usted que le interesó para investigar
precisamente a la etnia wayúu lo que me
interesa en el pueblo wayúu porque es un
pueblo indígena
es que se basa en una estructura
matrilineal lo que significa que las
madres transmiten el territorio y me
pareció como yo venía de una sociedad
muy patrilineal en cual nos habla el
nombre lo de cualquier todo claramente
es más de filiación no que el nombre del
territorio se transmite por las mujeres
por lo de los wayuu en una sociedad para
ti lineal el nombre y como enhancer por
ejemplo se transmite por los padres en
los guayos para los wayú no el clan uno
nos recibe de su madre pertenece al clan
de su madre esto es lo que le interesó
para estudiar precisamente ese ese grupo
se es y ahora bien para entender para
tratar de entender lo que ha significado
la evolución de lo que llevó a la
constitución del colectivo fuerza de
mujeres wayúu creo que es necesario
hacer referencia a los cambios que hubo
en la constitución colombiana en 1991
nos puede de manera resumida dar algunos
elementos que expliquen lo que va a
suceder después con ese grupo que es la
constitución del 91 nace de un esfuerzo
para
para lograr la paz en colombia porque
hay un
conflicto armado desde muchos años
entonces el presidente de la época
convoca una asamblea
constituyente constituyente cuando
muchos sectores de la sociedad civil
como las mujeres y también los indígenas
y entonces a partir de ésta
de esa de esa constitución los pueblos
indígenas tienen derechos colectivos
derechos sobre el territorio tiene su
territorio y entonces el territorio está
no se puede vender no se puede ser tiene
que salvaguardar no y se le otorga los
los pueblos indígenas se les reconoce su
papel en la salvaguardia del territorio
y en el hecho de que no se pueden mover
del territorio porque hay que saber que
en colombia hay muchos problemas de
minería y entonces el de los territorios
indígenas representa es como representan
30 por ciento del territorio nacional
pero en dentro de esos territorios se
como se esconden muchas
mientras minas es anna usted hace
referencia dice la sociedad wayúu es
particulares son series de matriarcado
pero al mismo tiempo hay una fuerte
predominancia de lo que es el la
heterosexualidad del patriarcado como
tal la dominancia de los hombres de las
mujeres sobre las mujeres porque el
matriarcado y la maquinaria edad no es
la misma cosa sea el matriarcado es como
más bien una utopía que nunca ha
existido en ninguna asociada del poder
está las mujeres la matriz linealidad
significa que la afiliación
pasa por las madres lo que puede o como
decir otorgar a las madres a las mujeres
un papel especial en la sociedad pero el
poder la autoridad tradicional en la
sociedad casi siempre no siempre o casi
siempre es de un hombre una mujer era
familia y ese poder tiene una serie de
consecuencias por ejemplo lo que es la
utilización de la división de la
utilización de mercancías
las mujeres tienen derecho simplemente a
transportar a comercializarlas los
hombres recogen las mujeres no tienen
derecho a conducir automóviles por
ejemplo entre otras cosas según explicó
este en su libro me equivoco no es que
no tienen no sé si sea no es que no
tienen derecho no lo es no se hace ver
una mujer que está conduciendo peor o en
el ámbito familiar si se pueden conducir
por la mayor parte del tiempo los
conductores los que transportan las
mercancías en los hombres bien
decíamos es la uahe es una región
inhóspita en cierta medida es árida por
lo que usted escribe en su libro a
partir de los años 70 hay un factor
externo que empezó a alterar la vida de
la comunidad que ha cambiado
sustancialmente la vida de esa comunidad
y es la existencia el desarrollo de la
mina de carbón el cerrejón la mina más
grande a cielo abierto hoy en día de
américa del sur que es lo que cambió con
el desarrollo de explotación de esta
mina para la comunidad para el pueblo
bueno pues ha cambiado muchas cosas
porque
la mina los sitios donde se recoge el
carbón está en el sur de la región se
construyó una
una vía férrea que va a estar el norte
y entonces como ya para empezar ahí como
todo eso de este tren que va y que y que
divide el territorio también como hace
una contaminación muy importante para
los paja para todo el mundo y se ve en
el tejido las mujeres wayúu tienen mucho
en el tejido se ve como todos los
titulares los telares se ve el polvo de
carbón
y entonces como la y el desplazamiento
también porque claro laminada quiere ir
en un sitio y entonces se lo arregla
para desplazar a la gente y justamente
con esta constitución del 91 para
desarrollar un proyecto sobre un
territorio toca hacia un
adulto con una consulta previa que es
también un derecho que reconoce las
naciones unidas con el convenio 169 de
la oit entonces esas empresas están en
la obligación de hacer una consulta
previa de convocar a la gente del pueblo
a ver si pueden o no si están de acuerdo
o no y muchas veces esta consulta previa
se transforma en
invita a la gente ajena
para tratar de ganar el consenso y
generamos o para ganar la mayoría hay
una cuestión que me interesó desde su
libro que es la referencia a la
presencia de fuerzas policiacas
militares paramilitares narcotraficantes
háblenos de eso porque se desarrollan
mucho más se potencia con la presencia
de la mina con la explotación de la mina
sí sé si ustedes se han desarrollado
mucho más a partir de la explotación de
la mina en los fuerzas paramilitares las
fuerzas de seguridad el narcotráfico ha
ido creciendo a la par que la mina se
extiende es que antes de los años 70 el
estado colombiano no tenía una presencia
muy fuerte en la región su presencia no
tenía como
la fuerza policial no había mucha
policía veo con la mina hay esta
obligación de proteger la mina o sea el
estado colombiano se compromete con los
dirigentes de la mina a proteger la mina
y entonces se observa a partir de los 80
sobre todo de los de los 80 y más
adelante una militarización de la
de la región al padre eso también
a paseo de los años 90 si se constituye
en colombia las alas de las autodefensas
unidas de colombia por militares el
grupo paramilitar sí que reúnen muchos
grupos para militar y entonces
desarrollan un bloque en el norte que
incluye la guajira y bueno se va
desarrollando y ellos lo que lo que
pretenden más bien es cómo controlar el
territorio para poder tener acceso de
los pistas de los pistas que hay en toda
la región para el el narcotráfico para
el transporte porque al final de la mina
también si se aprovecha de un hay muchos
puertos naturales
en el norte muy norte de la región en el
desierto
entonces la mina se aprovecha de eso y
también los los paramilitares se
aprovechan de esos puestos para mandar
la cocaína qué papel han jugado las
mujeres en este escenario en el
desarrollo de este escenario que usted
nos explica a las mujeres wayúu claro
está las mujeres sueño es que hay que
saber que en la en el pueblo wayúu hay
muchos conflictos muchos hay guerras sin
tener en dentro de las familias que fue
también las chuzadas se dicen españa
artistas por los paramilitares
entonces cuando en los años 2000 se dan
cuenta los pueblos el pueblo se da
cuenta de que se están matando y que se
están matando entre ellos pero que el
enemigo es el paramilitar de columbia ya
dicen no pues no no vamos a poder
sobrevivir a esta guerra porque los
hombres se estaban matando dentro de las
familias
entonces las mujeres
desempeñan un papel de liderazgo de ir a
reclamar reparación al estado de ira
reclamar de siero y aquí nos está tu
cuando el conflicto armado y usted
listado nos tienen que se nos deben unas
reparaciones porque nos están
estropeando nuestro territorio entonces
como los hombres hay también tienen que
ver con la estructura social why you
know que cuando hay una guerra a los
hombres van a la guerra y las mujeres
pueden moverse dentro del territorio de
manera más o menos libre y también van a
hablar a los van a ser facilitadora
porque pueden o sea tiene una libertad
que al final los hombres no van a tener
en tiempo
se aprovechan de ese aprovechan se
apoyan
deseaban de esta situación para exigir
reparación y exige exigir al estado de
hacer algo para que los paramilitares se
vayan
a nadie es a partir del año de la década
del 2000 entiendo bien que se desarrolla
mucho más el trabajo de conciencia de
toma de conciencia de las mujeres wayúu
que va a desembocar finalmente en la
creación de este colectivo es un paso
fundamental
el colectivo nace como en 2006 o 2007 y
lo que pasa es que a partir de los años
2000 los paramilitares ya están y ya se
están bien en la región y empiezan a
empoderarse de los de unos sitios en
territorio por el territorio eso
entonces el tiempo que se puede dar y el
tiempo que la gente se dé cuenta el
tiempo que hagan más acá es también los
2003 2004 2005 y que la gente se dé
cuenta de lo que está pasando ya estamos
en el 2006 2007
cuando se consume el colectivo de la
fuerza de mujeres cuello al despido el
tiempo se nos va muy rápidamente una
última pregunta estamos por cumplir
cinco años ya de la firma de los
acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno
colombiano y las fuerzas armadas
revolucionarias de colombia las farc
desde entonces hasta la fecha asesinados
más de 1200 dirigentes sociales según
indepaz sólo en este año van más de 121
asesinados algunos de ellos son
indígenas de manera muy breve que
representa esto para usted
hay mucha tristeza
pero vamos a ello la última vez que fue
a colombia llega en el 2019 fui con una
acompañada de la fachada de mujeres
wayúu hacia una conferencia en la
universidad de santa marta y ella vino
con un wise para la porque recibían
amenazas y todavía están recibiendo
amenazas
entonces la situación es bastante grave
y
todavía hay un problema de seguridad
para los líderes sociales para los
líderes indígenas y las mujeres
indígenas claro pues con estas palabras
estamos poniendo punto final a esta
escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecer a anne smith autora del libro
sexy territorial en colombia en
autóctona luto la tiene secret publicado
por ediciones la arma tan sexy
territorio en colombia mujeres
autóctonas en el siglo 21 anas gracias
por haber venido con nosotros bueno
muchas gracias invitarme y a ustedes les
damos otra cita aquí la próxima semana
en otra escala en parís
[Música]